[Music]
hey Conan O'Brien here and I'm at chick
elms
grand entry and Rodeo shop and this is
chick elms yesterday chick good to see
you how are you I'm fine you I'm doing
very well where'd you get the name chick
oh I don't know that's quite a yarn
what's your real name can't tell it
really it's a sillier than Conan
probably really sure can I what Cheryl
Cheryl mm-hmm your parents named you
Cheryl yep so you decided I'm gonna
change the name Cheryl to something much
more manly do you ever come across
someone who just doesn't look good in
western clothes does it always work it
just always were I got a challenge for
you I brought a friend of mine he's from
New York City don't get mad but he's
from New York some people have to be and
he's what we call a metrosexual you know
what that is okay take it easy it's not
what you think it's not something who
has sex with trains but he's a creep
his name is Jorden Lansky chick this is
jordyn slansky
we brought you here to this town about
sixty miles southwest of Fort Worth to
dress you up and make you a real cowboy
a real man because frankly I've worked
with you for a while and you have a bit
of an effete I'm gonna say European
style some of us who are true Americans
find offensive you're telling us a
beautiful language and I don't see the
problem with having Italian instructions
in the machine with some coffee broke
cheese on top on a baguette
this is a free Maserati yes miss cope to
me it's a piece filter biscotti that
would be if there's more than one
there's only one how did you feel about
getting dressed up in cowboy wear I'm
fine with it
okay be glad to fix you up
thank you check you guys have an amazing
chemistry some good cowboy boots okay
I'm noticing you got a fine selection
here I like these for Jordan yeah what
do you think that's got too much pink in
it you don't think pink what do you
think Jordan B I think things seems a
little bit of feminine really you think
it's a family well I wake up I have
cappuccino and a savory pastry twice a
week I shave remove excess hair then
shave exclusively your face I shave
other areas what other eras d-shape
Jordan various areas
another region that's a personal matter
Jim what do you think about a man that
shaved his body gosh I'm with you chick
look at that that's got a Native
American Flair
well most cowboy boots were influenced
by Native American designs even the
Spanish Vaquero designs so much so that
the term buckaroo used to describe the
Cowboys of the Great Basin for the west
of here comes from the word like arrow
narrating and documentary would you be
open to having playing cards on your
boots be honest well the great thing
about cowboy boots is is always a little
left to the imagination because this
area is covered up by jeans so yes that
would be open to that well not always my
guess is you'll be wearing these also
occasionally with just a European speedo
bathing suit that is the kind of bathing
suit you prefer is it not
I like four-inch insane
[Applause]
[Music]
this is what I decided
Georgia do you have any thoughts about
this outfit this isn't what I had in
mind
we're in what way it's all authentic
western gear I think it fits you
suitably what is the problem there's a
lot of excess bulk wear everywhere
the legs are tubular not here
then again today I'm good
this is fantastic look at this Jake I
love this belt this is a fantastic belt
it's got a little little color to it
some cowhide with the hair oh look at
that that's actual cow hair it's in
there Jordan one tip don't shave this
hair hit me sick
I've throw up under your shirt but it
looks like someone already has
[Applause]
okay a little smaller what about this
and we keep the bag on this way he's
protected if your coffees when you're
making it with your little Italian
machine and if i tire of listening to
you I can close this all minute your dad
what do you think this feels like a good
fit
there's the way we could steam it so
this comes down and I don't see his face
yeah when you get it down a little bit
what like it down a lot along you
excited about your new cowboy hat you
know it's interesting because it's a
misconception that the cowboy hat was
the head of the West traditionally
speaking it was an impractical design
because it would easily blow off so one
day West cowboy hat as we know a dude by
the promises though after the Civil War
due in large part to John Stetson who
was from New Jersey it's probably from
the Spanish Tom DeLonge which basically
means very gallant which is a
description of the Hat as it appeared
[Music]
yes this is perfect that's perfect
how do you feel Jordan I can't see
anything
I know Jordan thank you very much chick
you're a great man you're welcome
yeah real honor to meet you and Jordan
if you could find your way home
Hotel is about 85 miles from here on
foot you should get started cuz it gets
dark early okay
don't take the hat off he'll be dead in
an hour
[Applause]
- where - he's about four
good day he's really like that
[Laughter]
of looking around Dallas for a biscotti